[Music]  today local organizations are honoring  former nuclear weapons workers nuclear  Care Partners held an event to say thank  you to the men and women who work to  build and maintain our nation's nuclear  defense the organization provides  medical benefits and in-home care to  former Atomic workers who have developed  serious illnesses due to exposure to  harmful radiation and toxic chemicals  we're here to give back to them ensure  that they have the benefits that they  need for helping us with our country  they are our own Zone Heroes they helped  protect this nation and we are here to  celebrate them today  former nuclear workers received a pin as  well commemorating their service to our  country